projet hercules c'est le nom de code de
ce chantier qui a pour but de
réorganiser edf
objectif diviser électricité de france
en trois filiales edf bleus détenue à
100% par l'état
cette première entité regrouperait
toutes les activités nucléaires et rte
le réseau de transport de l'électricité
edf vers celle ci pourrait être cotée en
bourse comprendrait les activités
commerciales du groupe et serait en
charge des énergies renouvelables enfin
edf azur pour tout le secteur des
barrages hydrauliques unanimes dans leur
rejet de ce projet les syndicats du
groupe edf estime qu'il comporte je
signe de multiples dangers notamment
parce qu'ils y voient un démantèlement
du groupe et ont donc organisé plusieurs
actions pour dire non hercules le projet
recul s'inscrit dans un processus de
déconstruction méthodique d'un monopole
public dont tout le monde reconnaissait
pourtant le succès de son côté le
gouvernement nie toute volonté de
démantèlement
le souhait du gouvernement n'est
évidemment pas de déstabiliser un des
fleurons industriels français
seulement nous devons nous assurer que
le groupe dispose d'un cadre de
régulation adaptée et de capacité
d'investissement qui sont accrus pour
participer pleinement à la transition en
toile de fond de ce projet et recul il y
à ces négociations entre paris et
bruxelles
elles concernent notamment le prix du
nucléaire depuis 2011
edf est sous le coup du dispositif à
rennes pour accès régulé à l'énergie
nucléaire historique
il oblige le groupe à vendre à un prix
fixe un quart de sa production
d'électricité issue du nucléaire à ses
concurrents
1 mégawatt heure se vend donc
aujourd'hui à 42 euros trop peu pour edf
qui peinent à lancer des investissements
mais augmenter ce prix de vente
reviendrait pour la commission
européenne a entravé les règles de l'ue
eu un coup de pouce de l'état qu'elle
assimile à une entrave à la libre
concurrence
d'où ce projet hercules voulue par
l'état grâce auquel la filière edf bleus
pourraient revendre sa production issue
du nucléaire edf verts dans les mêmes
conditions qu'à ses concurrents hercules
a aussi provoqué une levée de boucliers
au sein de la classe politique à
l'assemblée nationale les parlementaires
socialistes proposent ainsi un
référendum ni
natif partagé pour contrer ce projet un
projet est également très critiqué par
les élus des groupes les républicains et
la france sont soumises les socialistes
de l'assemblée nationale et les
sénateurs ps propose aujourd'hui un
référendum d'initiative partagée pour
empêcher le démantèlement d'edf en
cassant edf le gouvernement affaibli la
souveraineté de notre pays est le
principal outil de notre transition
énergétique
cette séparation des activités fait
peser un risque inacceptable sur la
souveraineté du pays
où est la logique monsieur le premier
ministre et l industrielles ou
financières
ce projet d'achèvement du démantèlement
d'edf appelé hercules
l'idée du projet recul c'est de
continuer et de finir de saucissonner le
groupe en deux grandes entités d'un côté
vous auriez edf bleus une entité qui
resterait public et dans laquelle on
mettrait tout ce qui coûte très cher et
qui nécessite des investissements
colossaux pour être entretenue par
exemple le nucléaire et de l'autre vous
auriez une société ouverte au capital
privé
edf fr dans lequel il mettrait tout ce
qui peut rapporter de l'argent
de leur côté les syndicats entendent
continuer leur action ils en ont
organisé de nouvelles cette semaine à
travers le pays